[موسيقى]
ليست مجرده حافلات ملونه بل قاطره محمله
بالامل والدعم النفسي تشق طريقها بين
مخيمات للنازحين في شمال غرب سوريا لتصل
الى اطفال دمر الزلزال مدارسهم قبل اكثر
من ثلاثه اشهر لكنه لم ينل من حماستهم
لكسب العلم والمعرفه
التلاميذ بفرح الحصص الدراسيه التي تتنوع
بين اللغتين العربيه والانجليزيه والعلوم
والرياضيات المبادره تقف خلفها منظمه
اورنج المحليه غير الربحيه التي تركز
جهودها على بلده جنديرس الواقعه في محافظه
حلب والقريبه من الحدود التركيه وهي من
المناطق الاكثر تاثرا بالزلزال الذي ضرب
سوريا وتركيا المجاوره في السادس من شباط
فبراير وحصد ارواح قرابه سته الاف شخص في
سوريا وحدها
الباصات تستهدف 27 مخيم تتنقل بينها
اتباعا وايضا معلم الجوال لدينا عشر مراكز
منتشره في المخيمات مخيمات اللواء في
جنديرس وما حولها تغطي هذه الوحدات
التعليميه عدد من الطلاب يبلغ اكثر من
3000 طالب الح زلزال اضرارا كبيره
بالابنيه والمرافق الخدميه والبنا التحتيه
خصوصا في المناطق الحدوديه مع تركيا مركز
الزلزال في شمال غرب سوريا وحده يحتاج
اكثر من مليون طفلا في سن المدرسه الى دعم
تعليمي وهم معرضون لخطر التسرب من المدرسه
بسبب الزلزال وفق مكتب تنسيق الشؤون
الانسانيه التابعه للامم المتحده وتشير
التقديرات الى تضرر ما لا يقل عن
452 مدرسه ابتدائيه وثانويه بدرجات
متفاوته في وقت يحتاج فيه ما لا يقل عن 25
الف معلم
متضرر من الزلزال الى دعم الصحه العقليه
والدعم النفسي والاجتماعي والتعويض
المناسب وبناء القدرات وفي عموم سوريا
يحتاج ما يصل الى اربعه ملايين طفل
لمساعده انسانيه مستمره وفق منظمه الامم
المتحده للطفوله اليونيسف التي افادت ايضا
بان الزلزال عطل تعليمه ما يقرب من
مليونين طفل في وقت لا تزال مئات المدارس
التي نجت من الكارثه تستخدم لايواء
العائلات التي دمر زلزال منازلها